WELL HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US ON TODAY'S
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HEARING MY
BRUSH CALLED ME TO ORDER LIKE
OFFICIALS BY THE- AS WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
AFFECTED DELIBERATIONS AND
DECISIONS ON THE CRITICAL ISSUES
FACING CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. AT TODAY'S HEARING
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM
THOSE JOINING US IN THE ROOM
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAYBE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED. YOU CAN
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY
VISITING THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE
AT W. W. W. DOT E. M. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT C. A DOT GOV. WITH
THAT SAID FIRST LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HERE HERE YEAH.
HERE RIGHT. WALDRON WHERE
REPORTER RIGHT THANK YOU NOW WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
APPROVAL OF THE FIVE BILLS
AROUND CONSENT. ON CONCEPTS ARE.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
MARKANDE. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
CUNNINGHAM. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN RODRIGUEZ AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
PETRIE-NORRIS. AND AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY SIX THE COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. AND-
DRIVE A MOTION A SECOND MOTION
BY. AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BOOK A
CALDERON IN WITH THAT SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION FOR A
BI IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS
TO PASS WITH RECOMMENDATION TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE REP THE
MOTION FOR THE OTHER FOUR BILLS
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR RODRIGUEZ. HI
RODRIGUEZ AYE C. R. DEL SARTO
AYE AYE YEAR CURRY ARE YOUR
CURRY I CALDERON. CALDERON I
GRADE. WALDRON WALDRON I. FIVE
EYES. OKAY THAT MOTION IS OUT
ASSEMBLY WE DO HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM HERE- PHOTO NUMBER
FOUR TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW. SO WHEN
YOU ARE READY SIR THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
ONE WHICH MAKES IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO THE ELDER CALIFORNIA
PIPELINE SAFETY ACT. OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE. THAT WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT ALL INTRASTATE
PIPELINES ARE REGULARLY
INSPECTED AND SAFELY OPERATED.
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE HAS WORKED
HARD TO ESTABLISH A MEANINGFUL
AND EFFECTIVE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT ENSURES PIPELINE
SAFETY WHILE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION CONTINUES IN THE
STATE. THE ELDER CALIFORNIA
PIPELINE SAFETY ACT IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS
FRAMEWORK THE ACT DEFINES
PIPELINE TO INCLUDE. EVERY
INTERSTATE PIPELINE USED FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION OF HAZARDOUS
LIQUID SUBSTANCES OR HIGHLY
VOLATILE LIQUID SUBSTANCE AS
SPECIFIED HOWEVER THE ACT
EXCLUDES A PIPELINE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION OF CRUDE OIL THAT
OPERATES. BAG GRAVITY OR TO
STRESS LEVEL THAT IS LESS THAN
TWENTY PERCENT. OR LESS OF THE
SPECIFIED MINIMUM YIELD STRENGTH
OF THE PIPE. UNFORTUNATELY SOME
OF USE THIS EXCLUSION AS A
LOOPHOLE TO CIRCUMVENT
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE REGULATION
WHICH MEANS THAT- ESSENTIAL
SAFETY MEASURES SUCH AS
INSPECTIONS AND TESTING THAT
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY AND SAFE
OPERATION OF PIPELINES ARE NOT
MET. AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE
WILL CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE BY
REQUIRING INSPECTION FOR ALL
INTERSTATE PIPELINES WHETHER
THEY'RE OPERATING AT FULL OR
PARTIAL PRESSURE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT- THESE ANNUAL
<c.red>NSPECTIONS ARE NOT EXCESSIVELY</c>
ONEROUS BUT THEY'RE CRITICAL FOR
ALL PARTIES TO AVOID DAMAGE AND
LOSSES FROM OIL SPILLS. THIS
BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THAT
PIPELINE OPERATORS MUST KEEP
RECORDS IN A USABLE AND READABLE
FORM. AND PROVIDE THAT THOSE
WORK AND PROVIDE THOSE RECORDS
UPON REQUEST BY THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. AGAIN THIS WILL ALLOW
STATE REGULATORS TO SAFEGUARD
PIPELINE OPERATIONS AND PROTECT
THE STATE COMMUNITIES THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ULTIMATELY THE
INTEGRITY OF THE INDUSTRY ITSELF
IN THE WAKE OF LAST YEAR'S
ORANGE COUNTY SPILL THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO HELP
ENSURE THAT ALL STATE REGULATED
PIPELINES. ARE REGULARLY
INSPECTED AND MAINTAINED SO THAT
DAMAGE TO A PIPELINE DOES NOT
LEAD TO YET ANOTHER CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOME. IS TO BE JOINED BY
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY MISS ALL
ROMERO MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS PLEASED TO
BE HERE WITH IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLAME IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE. WHICH IS
A COMMON SENSE MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL INTERSTATE PIPELINES
ARE REGULARLY INSPECTED AND
MAINTAINED WHILE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION CONTINUES IN THE
STATE. THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
REGULATES THE SAFETY OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILES OF INTERSTATE HAZARDOUS
LIQUID TRANSPORTATION PIPELINES
AND ACTS AS AN AGENT OF THE
FEDERAL OFFICE OF PIPELINE
SAFETY. CONCERNING THE
INSPECTION OF MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND MILES OF INTERSTATE
PIPELINES. IT DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE TO EXCLUDE ANY PIPELINE
IT'S TRANSPORTING HAZARDOUS
LIQUID SUBSTANCE IN OUR STATE
FROM REGULAR INSPECTIONS AND
TESTING. EACH ONE HAS HAD A
CATHOLIC HAS HAD A CATASTROPHIC
. SORRY AS ALL OF THEM POSE A
RISK TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY IF
THEY ARE NOT PROPERLY
MAINTAINED. OUR STATE'S HISTORY
OF OIL SPILLS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF
DEMONSTRATING. UP FROM THIS
POINT FROM THE SANTA BARBARA OIL
SPILL IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE TO
OF COURSE THE OIL SPILL FROM
LAST YEAR AND ORANGE COUNTY.
EACH ONE HAS HAD A CATASTROPHIC
IMPACT ON OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
NATURAL RESOURCES WILDLIFE- AND
THIS THESE EVENTS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE IS. NOT A
FAIL SAFE WAY TO EXTRACT AND
TRANSPORT OIL BUT REGULAR
INSPECTIONS AND PROPER
MAINTENANCE OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ESSENTIAL TO
MINIMIZING THE RISK FUTURE OIL
SPILLS. AND ASA FAMILY MEMBER
BLOOM NOTED THESE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS ARE NOT EXCESSIVELY
ONEROUS THEREFORE REQUIRING ALL
INTERSTATE PIPELINES TO BE
REGULATED. REGARDLESS OF
OPERATING PRESSURE IS SENSIBLE
FROM BOTH AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
INDUSTRY STANDPOINT. AND IS
CRITICAL FOR ALL PARTIES TO
AVOID DAMAGE AND LOSSES FROM OIL
SPILLS. SERVER THESE REASONS
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU WITH THAT IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
FOR SUPPORT HIS NAME REGULATION
ONLY COME FORTH. SEEN NONE.
THANK YOU I BELIEVE THERE'S
SOMEONE HERE TO FIND OPPOSITION.
PARTY WITH THE RUSSIANS THE
STATE'S PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
YOU MAY PROCEED. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FULL WE HAVE THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION- SIMILAR TO S. B.
ONE SIXTY NINE FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THIS BILL IS IDENTICAL
AND AT THAT TIME WE ATE WE HAD
EXPRESSED CONCERNS NOW WITH THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL OR THE
INSPECTIONS JUST THE HANDLING OF
THE VERY SENSITIVE- PIPELINE
INFORMATION. OF WHICH THE OFFICE
OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL IS TO
COLLECT- THAT'S IT THAT'S REALLY
OUR MAIN CONCERN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS. OKAY THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. C. NONE THANK YOU-
GIVEN THE CONCERNS I WANT TO
OVERSEE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION MOVING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE. NONE SO
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS
SUGGESTIONS SAN WITHOUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES- AT THANK YOU AGAIN-
OF A STRUCTURE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WE CERTAINLY WILL-
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH OPPOSITION TO SEE IF WE CAN
RESOLVE. OR NARROW THE GAP
BETWEEN US AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT OKAY AND WITH
THAT WE DO HAVE MOTION A SECOND
. THE MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND. I
THINK MOTION A SECOND MOTION BY
CECILIA SECOND BOMBS CALDERON
AND WHAT THAT WOULD DO A MOTION
SEEKING TO PASS ON TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS US
SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I SEYARTO
NO. CERTAIN NO AGUIAR-CURRY. I
YEAR CURRY I CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE GRAY. WALDRON WARD. THREE
EYES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN AND- FOR THE
MISSION MEMBERS SO NOW WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE FILE.
THANK YOU. SHARE YOUR TOTAL
KELLY A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY RUSSIA. THANK
YOU ARE A WHEELCHAIR I AM HERE
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
SO UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
CALIFORNIA REGENCY SERVICES ACT
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
SUSPEND ANY REGULATION OR
STATUTE DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY POWERS ALSO GRANT THE
ABILITY TO SUSPEND ANY LOCAL
REGULATION OR LAW. ALL THESE
POWERS ARE AUTHORIZED UPON THE
DECLARATION OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND REMAIN IN EFFECT
THROUGH THE END OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY EMERGENCY POWERS EXIST
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE STATE TO
RESPOND IN A TIMELY AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER. TO AN IMMINENT
CRISIS. CONSEQUENTLY HAS BEEN A
LONG HELD ASSUMPTION THE
EMERGENCY POWERS WILL ONLY BE
EXERCISED TO RESPOND TO
CONDITIONS RELATING TO THAT
STATE OF EMERGENCY. HOWEVER AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN CALIFORNIA LAW
DOES NOT LIMIT EMERGENCY POWERS
TO THAT END. THE LAW IN ITS
EXISTING STE STATE AUTHORIZES
THE POWERS PREVIOUSLY SPECIFIED
SIMPLY UNDER THE CONDITION THAT
A STATE OF EMERGENCY EXISTS.
EVEN IF THOSE POWERS ARE
EXERCISED TO RESPOND TO AN
UNRELATED ISSUES OR CONDITIONS.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY TWENTY FIVE
OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
RANGING FROM NEW YORK TO ALASKA
THEY HAVE STATUTES SPECIFYING
THAT EMERGENCY POWERS MUST BE
USED TO RESPONSE BUT CIVICALLY
TO CONDITIONS RELATING TO THE
EMERGENCY. AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WOULD JOIN CALIFORNIA WITH
THESE THOSE STATES IN
MAINTAINING THEIR CLEAR GUIDANCE
UNDER EMERGENCY POWERS STATUTE
BY CODIFYING THE ASSUMPTION THAT
EMERGENCY POWERS ARE AUTHORIZED
ONLY IN THE SCOPE AS THEY RELATE
TO THE SPECIFIC CONDITIONS OF
THE EMERGENCY. AND THIS IS JUST
SIMPLY A GOOD GOVERNANCE TYPE
BILL THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE OUT BRING
US OR ANYONE IN THE ROOM LIKE TO
SPEAK OPPOSITION. SEE NON BRING
BACK REMEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. C. NONE I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE-
MOTION A SECOND- RIGHT MOTIONS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SURE THE
SECOND MOTION AND A SECOND- SO
THAT IF SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I KNOW I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK VERY
MUCH I DO HAVE I RECOUP- SECTOR
CALDERON MOTIONS TO PASS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ AYE SECTOR AYE CERTO
AYE I'VE YEAR CURRY I YOU'RE
CURRY I CALDERON. CALDERON I
GREAT. WALDRON WARD. SIX PLEA
BUT OPEN ALL RIGHT WILL CONTINUE
HAVE THE ROLLOVER FOR ANY
MISSING MEMBERS SO THE NEXT ONE
ON IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO
AGUIAR-CURRY. WHEN YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OKAY. SELECTION
OF FISH WITH THE REGULAR.
ALL RIGHT GOTIT. ALL RIGHT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER I'M
HERE TODAY TO A TWENTY FIFTY
WHICH REQUIRES THE PUMP UTILITY
COMMISSION TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON BROADWAY SERVICE
EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND REPLACE
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE AFTER
EMERGENCIES OR DISASTERS. YOU
KNOW THE WILDFIRES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
CAUSED MASSIVE DEVASTATION FOR
PROPERTY LOSS TO LOSS OF
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS
DAMAGE. MANY PEOPLE REPORT THAT
THEIR MOBILE PHONES WENT DARK
AND INTERNET SERVICE WHEN OUT OF
CELL TIME TOWERS WERE DAMAGED AN
UNDERGROUND FIBER LINES WERE
BURNED. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AN ONLINE SURVEY FOUND
THAT 64% OF RESPONDENTS IN THE
CINEMA COUNTY AS WELL FAR.
AFFECTED THEIR LOST HIM LAND
LINE PHONE SERVICE. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE GAS FIRE. GET I
CLASSIFIER REPORTED DAMAGE
ATTEMPT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE CAUSING
DISRUPTIONS IN PHONE SERVICE IN
THE AFFECTED AREA. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES THE STATE THE PC HAVE FOR
FOCUS HEAVILY ON THE UTILITIES
RESPONSE TO THE MASS OF
DESTRUCTION. EVEN TODAY LITTLE
IS KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL IMPACT
OF THESE NATURAL DISASTERS HAVE
HAD ON OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS AND HOW
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED. CONCRETE
RECOVERY PLANS ARE NOT SHARED
WITH THE PC. OR THE LEGISLATURE
WHOSE JOB IS TO OVERSEE THESE
COMPANIES AND TO REPRESENT THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. WE NEED THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE
GOVERNMENTS ARE HELPING IN THIS
REPAIR EFFORTS AND NOT IMPEDINGTHE RESTORATION. AB TWELVE
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO REQUIRES
THE PC TO COLLECT INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE THAT NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. AFTER THE
EMERGENCIES OR DISASTERS. I WANT
TO STRESS THAT THE BILL'S
REQUIRED REPORTING IS NOT
MANDATED TO BE SUBMITTED DURING
THE EMERGENCIES THEMSELVES BUT
IS INSTEAD A LOOK BACK TO MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN THE SHORT
TERM. DURING EMERGENCIES AN
APPROPRIATE SERVICE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL ECONOMIES AFTER DOES THE
DISASTER IN THE LONG TERM. AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT STATE REGULATORS
AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS ARE
INFORMED OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE FAILURES. AND NETWORK
DAMAGE AFTER DISASTER NATURAL
DISASTER. WITHOUT INFORMATION
REGARDING THE METHODS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY USED TO REBUILD
THERE'S NO WAY TO ENSURE THE
RESIDENTS HAVE THE SAME OR
IMPROVED ACCESS TO RELIABLE
NETWORK. FOR THE FOR MOST
CALIFORNIANS RELIABLE VOICE
TELEPHONE SERVICES NECESSARY TO
REACH NINE ONE ONE WITHOUT IT
THE ABILITY TO CONTACT EMERGENCY
SERVICES LIMITED OR NON EXISTENT
. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY- IN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ARE FRANK
ERRORS SAY. MAN RIGHT. AND
REGINA COSTA A RETURN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WITH THAT- WHO LIKE TO GO FIRST
FRANK WOOD YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FRANK I DON'T SEE IT BUT IT'S
THE TOUGHEST FOUR LETTERS IN TH
WORLD. ITSELF IT'S NO GOOD I AM
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE WE ARE CO SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO.
DISTRICT NINE COVERS CALIFORNIA
NEVADA AND HAWAII AND WE
REPRESENT THE WORKERS IN THE
TELECOMMUNICATION INDUSTRY'S AND
ABORTS A BROAD SPECTRUM OF OTHER
INDUSTRIES WE ASK THAT YOU PASS
A. B. TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO TO
ENSURE THAT OUR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FULLY AND
PROPERLY RESTORED FOLLOWING A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY. CW
A MEMBERS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
SENT OUT TO THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WHERE THE
B. URBAN OR RURAL TO RESTORE
SERVICE AND REBUILD CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHEN THERE IS
DAMAGE CAUSED BY A WIDE VARIETY
OF EVENTS. OUR MEMBERS AND
WORKERS ARE THE ONES TRYING TO
GET FAMILIES BACK ONLINE AND
BACK CONNECTED. OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY HOME EVERY
INTERNET CONNECTION IS BACK UP
AND BACK IN THE SHORTEST TIME
POSSIBLE. AND IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE MEANS POSSIBLE FOR
LONG TERM SERVICE TO STAYING
ABILITY. INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE BEEN SEEN THERE
BROADBAND SERVICE INTERRUPTED
BECAUSE OF EMERGENCY LIKE DURING
THE AFOREMENTIONED GLASS FIRED
CINEMA COUNTY IN TWENTY TWENTY.
OUR WORKERS ARE OFTEN THE ONES
HEARING FROM CUSTOMERS ABOUT
THESE KINDS OF SERVICE
INTERRUPTIONS. WE BELIEVE
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT IS NEEDED TO
ENSURE PROPER PROPER SERVICE
RESTORATION. TEMPORARY MEASURES
DEPLOYED AFTER THE FACT
FOLLOWING A DISASTER ARE NOT
GOOD ENOUGH. FOR EXAMPLE DRONES
AND MOBILE TOWERS ON TRUCKS
PROVIDE ONLY LIMITED. TEMPORARY
RESTORATION NOT A REPLACEMENT
FOR REAL CONNECTIVITY. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT OUR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE RESTORED FOR
EVERY CUT. AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
TWO WILL LAY GROUNDWORK TO
ADDRESS HOW PROVIDERS REBUILD
WHOLE COMMUNITIES AFTER
DISASTERS. ARE THEY INSTALLING
UPGRADES WHENEVER POSSIBLE. OR
ARE THEY JUST DOING THE BARE
MINIMUM LEAVING THE NETWORK
OUTDATED AND UNABLE TO BE
TODAY'S AND TOMORROW'S NEEDS WE
OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
TO LEARN THE LESSONS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE WILD FARMS AND
TO RESTORE OUR ABILITY TO HOLD
PROVIDERS ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE THEY SERVE. AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO TAKES IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
AND WE ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT ORIGINAL. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY. I'M
REGION ACOSTA SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK A
CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO. DURING THE PAST FEW
YEARS THE IMPORTANCE A RELIABLE
TELECOM AND BROADBAND SERVICE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. HAS BEEN
BROUGHT INTO SHARP RELIEF BY
BOTH THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND THE MANY DECLARED
DISASTERS EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. RELIABLE BROADBAND
DURING DISASTERS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
INFORMATION DURING EMERGENCIES
FOR EXAMPLE TO REACH WEBSITE
SUCH AS ALERT WILDFIRE DOT ORG.
LAST YEAR THE CPUC REQUIRED
TELECOM SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT DAMAGE
TO INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS BY
DECLARED DISASTERS. INCLUDING
THE DAMAGE AND THE STEPS TAKEN
TO REPAIR OR REBUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE C. P. U. C.
ACTION ADDRESS MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE PRIOR BILL AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED. BUT THE CPUC
ACTION DID NOT COVER BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO ADDRESSES THAT BY
REQUIRING THE CPUC TO ALSO
COLLECT INFORMATION ABOUT DAMAGE
ROOF- AND REBUILDING OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
RESULTING FROM A DECLARED
DISASTER. FOR ALL BROADBAND
PROVIDERS THE BILL HAS THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT THAT THE
CPC REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WHILE FOLLOWING THE CPC'S
EXISTING PROCEDURES RELATING TO
THE DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION.
THERE IS- OTHER DATA. UNDERTAKEN
BY CAL- YES ABOUT TELECOM
SERVICE OUTAGES IN REAL TIME TO
SUPPORT THE WORK OF EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS THE ACTION REQUIRED BY
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO SERVES A
DIFFERENT PURPOSE. THE REPORT
WILL PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE COMMISSION WITH A LONG TERM
PERSPECTIVE ON THE RELIABILITY
OF BROADBAND FOR ALL COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. TO HELP INSURE
THAT NO COMMUNITY IS LEFT BEHIND
WE WERE SPLIT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. SAM
NUNN. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION FOR. CAN I
GET. RIVAS RIGHT. WITH YOUR TERM
CHRIS BERNIER OSCAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE BUT WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION AND WE WERE IN
OPPOSITION FOR NUMBER REASONS SO
FIRST OF ALL WE AGREE WE AGREE
WITH THE FIRES THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THEY WERE HORRIBLE
THEY DESTROYED OUR NETWORKS WE
HAD ON FIBER UNDERGROUND IN LAKE
COUNTY THAT MELTED SO- THIS THE
FARMERS WERE HORRIBLE. BUT WE
RESTORED AND THEY WERE ALL
RESTORED A LOT HAS HAPPENED
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
LESSONS HAVE BEEN LEARNED SO
HOPEFULLY FOLKS ROUND TABLE WILL
LEARN THE SAME LESSONS. FIRST OF
ALL. SIR MCGUIRE HAD LEGISLATION
SB SIX SEVENTY IN A SENIOR NOW
SAYS. SB SIX SEVENTY SAYS THAT
WE MUST AS COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE MUST. SHARE IT WITH
CAL OH YES. INFORMATION ABOUT
OUR COMPANY CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHAT WAS
DESTROYED HOW LONG IS IT TAKING
TO BE DESTROYED WHEN WILL BE
BACK UP AND RUNNING AND WHEN IS
UP AND RUNNING. THAT IS
INFORMATION ONLY SHARED WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRST
RESPONDERS BECAUSE IT IS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
ADDITION TO THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. D. P. YOU SEE
ADOPTED RESILIENCY REQUIREMENTS
FOR WIRELESS INDUSTRY SO YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE WIRELESS
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK GOING
DOWN. AND WE AND WE GOT THAT AND
WE LEARNED A LESSON FROM THAT
AND THE P. SHE MADE A DECISION.
ADOPTED NEW ZEALAND- RULES FOR
RESTORATION. THEN IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THE PC FINALLY
ADOPTED. SIMILAR RESILIENCY
REQUIREMENTS FOR WIRED
COMMUNICATIONS IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE MUST HAVE BACKUP POWER
FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS. TO MAKE
SURE THOSE COMMUNICATIONS ARE UP
AND RUNNING DURING- DISASTERS
DURING PS PS. AND WHATNOT SO WE
HAVE DONE A LOT NOW IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR FOLKS SAY
WELL. THAT THOSE RULES AND THAT
LEGISLATION WAS TIED TO
COMMUNICATIONS IT WASN'T TIED TO
BROADBAND. SO THIS IS GOING TO
BE A REAL SHOCK TO- COMMITTEE
IT'S THE SAME NETWORK SO THAT
WAY IF IT GOES OUT OF THE VOICE
GOES OUT. ROBIN GOES OUT YOUR
TELEMEDICINE GOES OUT. YOUR
VOICE COMMUNICATIONS YOUR VIDEO
SERVICE SO IT ALL GOES OUT IT IS
THE SAME NETWORK IT IS MORE OR
LESS THE SAME NETWORK THAT GOES
OUT. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES KNOW
IT ASKS FOR DIFFERENT TYPE OF
INFORMATION AND WHAT IS GIVEN TO
CAL OH YES AND CAL OH YES IT IS
ABOUT. THE SERVICE WHAT IS THE
SERVICE AND ALL THE SERVICES ARE
HONORED TO BROADBAND VOICE AND
VIDEO. COMMUNICATIONS THIS BILL
WANTS TO KNOW ABOUT TECHNOLOGY
SORT OF PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
SO WHEN YOU RESTORED WHAT DID
YOU RESTART WITH WELL WHO'S
ASKING WOULD YOU WANT TO KNOW SO
IS SERVE SOME PURPOSE TO THAT.
OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE.
COMMUNICATION SERVICES THE
BROADBAND SERVICES IT IS NOT TO
GET INTO WHAT. THE DEVICES WE
ARE USING. NOW I KNOW THEY SAY
IN THIS BILL THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION IN
REAL TIME WELL GUESS WHAT YOU
HAVE TO COLLECTED IN REAL TIME.
EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T GIVE IT TO
YOU RIGHT AWAY. YOU STILL HAVE
TO COLLECTED IN REAL TIME SO.
THAT'S A DISTRACTION WE'RE
TRYING TO GET NETWORKS UP AND
RUNNING. THEN TO SAY A BUT WE
KNOW WE GOT TO GET THIS FOR. THE
PC THEY'RE GONNA WANT THIS
<c.red>NFORMATION I DON'T KNOW WHY.</c>
BUT THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE
IT TO YOU IN AN ANNUAL REPORT
NOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO WITH
THAT I'M NOT SURE. IT SOUNDS
LIKE. IF THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT RESTORATION EFFORTS. YOU
WOULD THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
PRECEDENT SOMEWHERE SO. IN THEIR
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF THIS
BILL. WE'VE ASKED FOR IF THERE'S
A PROBLEM SOMEWHERE IF THERE'S A
COMMUNITY SOMEWHERE WHERE THERE
WAS NOT PROPER RESTORATION.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW. TELL ME
WHERE THAT COMMUNITY WHAT'S- IF
YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC COMMUNITY
THAT WAS NOT RESTORED. TO ITS
FULL EXTENT OR BETTER. I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW. SO MAYBE RATHER
THAN. REQUIRING A REPORT MAYBE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU JUST
WANT TO DO A STUDY MAYBE JUST GO
BACK AND- YOU KNOW YOU. THE
INCIDENTS HAVE HAPPENED. THIS IS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS FIVE YEARS
AGO. SO IF YOU WANT TO DO A LOOK
BACK I HEARD THAT. THE PHRASE
LOOK BACK I'M AN EX AUDITOR
GENERAL. STAFF SO I WAS AN
AUDITOR FOR THREE AND HALF
YEARS. AND I LOVE ON ITS I LOVE
GOING BACK I LOVE YOU'RE FINE
OU KNOW WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED
SINCE THE INITIAL INCIDENT HAS
OCCURRED. TO RATHER THAN ASSUME
THAT. SOMETHING IS AMISS. MAYBE
WE SHOULD CONFIRM THAT IT IS A
MESS SO. UNTIL WE HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC REASON WHY- WE WOULD
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE. IF IT WERE
CONSISTENT WITH INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY CALLOVIAN ASPECTS
MAYBE INFORMATION COULD BE
SHARED BUT IT'S DIFFERENT. AGAIN
WHY THE TECHNOLOGY WHAT WHO
WHO'S ASKING WHY DO YOU WANT. SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED. I THANK YOU- ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION YES. YOUR LONG
THE BENSON WITH US TELECOM WE
ARE. REPRESENTATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA FACILITY BASED. WIRE
LINE. TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
BROUGHT PROVIDER- BELIEVE THAT.
WE HAPPENED. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY TWO DOES IS ACTUALLY.
OUTSIDE OF THE PURVIEW OF THE PC
AS FAR AS- ITS LEGAL AUTHORITY.
TO COLLECT THIS INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT'S BEYOND THEIR
JURISDICTION BECAUSE BROADBAND
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE NOT
PUBLIC. UTILITIES AS IS
CURRENTLY WHY THE PC CAN COLLECT
INFORMATION SUCH AS THIS. AND AS
MENTIONED AS BERNIE MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED THE PC ALREADY
REQUIRES DISASTER IN PLAN
RESTORATION INFORMATION TO BE
FILED. WE BELIEVE THAT THE FCC.
ALSO HAS AN OPENING. UP AN OPEN
PROCEEDING RIGHT NOW REGARDING
NETWORK RESILIENCY AND NETWORK
OUTAGE REPORTING WE BELIEVE THAT
ANYTHING THAT WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA'S PACIFIC WOULD BE IN
DIRECT CONFLICT. WITH POTENTIAL
THE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT WILL BE COMING
OUT. FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
TWO AND WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM OPPOSITION. SEE NON WILL
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS VICE
CHAIR SIR TELL YOU HAVE A
COMMENT QUESTION YES THEY DO- SO
. YEAH I HAD PROBLEMS WITH THIS
BEFORE AND IT SENT SOME OF IT
WAS RELATED TO THE INFORMATION
GOING OUT IMMEDIATELY AND YOU
KIND OF ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE
BIT HERE. BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS
IT BEING THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE WERE TRYING
TO FOCUS ON THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PART AND WE'RE KIND
OF TALKING ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS ONE OF IS YOU KNOW WHAT
DO WE DO IMMEDIATELY. TO GET-
COMMUNICATIONS BACK UP. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE ALWAYS DEAL
WITH IN THE FIRE SERVICE- IT'S
AND IT'S A CRITICAL
COMMUNICATIONS IS THE MOST
CRITICAL ELEMENT. AND SO THAT
WHEN WE'RE DOING THAT PART OF
IT- SPEED- IS WAY MORE IMPORTANT
THAN- THE YOU KNOW THE LINE LOVE
THE LONGER OUTLOOK. AND THEN
THERE'S THE LONGER OUTLOOK AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOUR BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS- MAKE CALLAWAY
ELSE DOES ALREADY COLLECT- THEY
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO COORDINATE.
ALL OF THE DOWNED POWER ALL THE
OUTAGES AND ALL THOSE THINGS
ALREADY AND IT JUST SEEMS
DUPLICATIVE FROM EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PART. TO BE TRYING TO
DO THAT- I THINK IS ONE
GENTLEMAN IT STATED. IT IT KIND
OF MONIES UP WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOIG WHICH IS AS
RAPIDLY AS POSSIBLE GETTING
PEOPLE BACK TO COMMUNICATING.
AND- AND- WHAT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS LONGER
TERM IT SEEMS IS. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UPGRADE SYSTEMS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THEN THAT
BECOMES PART OF RATE PAYER
ISSUES WHERE DOES THE STATE COME
IN TO TRY TO HELP UPGRADE THOSE-
THE- THOSE NAY COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES- BUT DURING
THE A MANAGE THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PART OF IT. IT'S
ABOUT THE MOBILE MOBILE
COMMUNICATION TRACK SWITCHER OF
KIND OF IN IT YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE- ACCESSIBILITY LIMITED A
LIMITS- AS THEY'RE TRYING TO
POSITION THEMSELVES BUT THERE'S
ALSO COMMUNICATIONS TOWERS THESE
LITTLE MOBILE COMMUNICATIONS
TOWERS. THEY CAN BE SET UP
TEMPORARILY- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK THE STATE ROLE
BUT I SHOULD BE THAT'S SOMETHING
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT IT FROM
THE STATE PERSPECTIVES. AS
BEING. YOU KNOW READYING
OURSELVES FOR THESE TYPE OF
EMERGENCIES- BUT I I'M NOT READY
TO. GET ON BOARD WITH HAVE IT
WITH THE P. YOU SEE- JUMP IN
AGAIN- WITH MORE MANDATE- WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO RECOVER FROM.
THE PREVIOUS STEP FIVE I MEAN- I
THINK A GREAT EXAMPLE IS THE
HOME REBUILDING PROCESS THEY'RE
STRUGGLING MIGHTILY. BECAUSE
THEY'VE BECOME FOCUSED O